los oficiales de policía de la fuerza de
élite abandonaron francia el domingo su
destino las islas caribeñas de guadalupe
pero no por vacaciones este territorio
francés de ultramar a eeuu por tres
noches en violentas protestas contra las
medidas del pasaporte de vacunación del
cob y 19 está en vigor un toque de queda
nocturno pero eso no impidió que algunos
prendieron fuego en las barricadas y
algunos incluso dispararon contra los
coches de la policía la imposición el
viernes un toque de queda a las 6 de la
tarde en todo el territorio es sólo una
de las medidas con las que los
manifestantes están enojados porque les
pide a los jóvenes que se queden en casa
porque estamos en contra de un pasaporte
de vacunas ese sistema es simplemente
ridículo le dieron a los manifestantes
de los chalecos amarillos en parís que
se quedarán en casa el sábado por la
noche las autoridades lucharon contra
los saqueos esporádicos en múltiples
áreas así como contra el vandalismo en
cuanto a pitt al menos 20 tiendas fueron
saqueadas 38 personas fueron arrestadas
por la policía en la noche del sábado y
al amanecer el desastre de la noche
anterior permanecía en las calles para
algunos las razones detrás de los
disturbios van más allá de la medida de
kobe
los jóvenes se rebelan contra la
situación social que no parece
ofrecerles futuro
necesitamos trabajo es todo el pasaporte
de la vacuna y todo eso no es bueno no
necesitamos vacunas aquí el primer
ministro jan castex se reúne este lunes
en parís con funcionarios de guadalupe
para discutir la situación